alright I think we're alive all right so
assuming that we're alive hello
everybody and welcome to this week's
episode of Android design in action we
don't have a theme or topic this week or
any set of redesigns today what we'll be
doing instead is having a hang out with
a bunch of folks from the design
community this I don't know if this is
like you know public and free to join I
mean I'm not free to join if you're able
to join if you for some reason cannot
join you do want to join just go to the
Google+ page for Android developers and
leave a comment on this post and we'll
go ahead and invite you so that you can
join um so we're just going to have kind
of a Q&A general discussion type of
event today before we get started let's
do some quick introductions for folks
that are already here I'll start so I'm
Roman Nurik I'm on our Android developer
relations team at Google and I'm one of
the co-hosts of Android design in action
hey guys Adam crushed I'm also one of
the co-host on the show we go over to
London hey yeah so Nick butcher here and
another Android about the advocate and
joined by Chris Bane's is also one of
the dev role for android but i guess
this week our are that you can come into
this girl's forgot all right shree head
over to Murray hi I'm Marie I'm Android
designer since four years and now in
bowlin as creative director for Nevada
awesome and are you honey hey guys sorry
I'm you honey uh I'm uh I'm a developer
why would you sign fan um I've wrote a
book smashing ever to I and bright a
block in Android UI patterns of calm and
I work for snap TV cool all right we
also have so DeAndre was here and then
he left let's head over to andreas
address you want to introduce yourself
and uh or if you if you want do you have
any questions immediate questions you
want to ask
orna okay um let's head over to DeAndre
how about you how's it going man hey you
yeah you're just fun D'Andre um okay i
I'm a android developer and designer um
in San Francisco cool welcome in and we
also have Lucas hey Lucas has gone I'm
gonna introduce yourself real quick
don't hear me yeah can you use mine okay
so um I work for Mozilla my big job is
Mozilla working on Firefox for Android
and i also created an app called patent
so wallpaper app got quite a few
downloads on google play yeah it's been
featured numerous times good stuff yeah
all right let's see who else is here I
think David Joan go ahead and unmute you
good sir and uh Ronnie lamp so um if
anybody hasn't introduced themselves and
wants to feel free otherwise let's jump
into the meat of today which is kind of
general discussion in QA so um before we
actually have a Google moderator page
setup we have a few questions in there
and we'll get to that you know if
there's time um but if anybody has any
initial kind of points of discussion or
you know topics they want to raise or
questions that you want you know other
folks to provide their feedback on
please go ahead and ask so anybody want
to kick things off with their own
questions or pointy yeah discussion no
no one's got any questions I think exam
I have a topic we can discuss why I
don't have a request yeah you only want
to go ahead and introduce its happen um
so um the up and slide navigational data
or navigation
it's great right but it's quite messy
right now so kind of finna to figure out
how it should work right it's now the
even the Google applications were quite
differently like Google Plus you can
swipe it from YouTube you can swipe the
Prince deploy navigation notes and so on
I wonder if you guys have a kind of
recommendation what what you feel the
interaction which of you got a reserve
of bezel swipe for it or its wife always
work and and my personal opinion about
the the icon is that it's the UPIKE and
I know you guys haven't but let's see
what's going to happen with that I work
mostly about the interaction like
swiping yourself how you feel what
zoopla hmm so um I guess we could
probably talk and talk about the
navigation drawer i'll probably take up
some time and that was actually the
number one question the moderate if you
got something like 20 boats um I
actually I I put together a little kind
of little bit of not only documentation
it's the unofficial kind of
recommendations from our team about um
you know what we've been recommending to
folks you know publicly as well as
internally and we could probably start
with that so let me just share that real
quick and then as you guys want to you
know you know talk about what your
feelings are towards towards the subject
then you'll feel free so I'm going to
screen share my tiny little guide on
navigation drawers don't know if you
guys consider yes can see that yep so
the current guidelines are basically a
drawer is a slide-out menu that allows
users to switch between views of your
app and you know it's it's obviously
exposed using the action bars app icon
with the up carrot and revealed by an
edge swipe and actually in some cases
like the YouTube app there it's not
really an edge swipe it so it's a full
screen swipe anything that makes sense
you know one personally that my opinion
is that it makes a lot of sense to do it
a full screen swipe when there aren't
competing gestures like for example if
you don't have swipe to dismiss actually
long aj just join let me unmute AJ AJ
how's it going so um you know when you
do not swipe to dismiss
or you don't have you know other
horizontal gestures like for example a
map as your primary content view I think
it makes sense if you like a full screen
slide because that's probably what
people are trying to do anyway that's
just again it's really my opinion and
the current guidelines say edge swipe
and I'd say that you know by default you
should probably just use the edge slide
um the other thing is that where is it
where is it is only suitable for the
topmost level so another thing that
folks sometimes use drawers for and not
home we need onion join the other thing
that people use jar is for us to kind of
provide exposed global navigation
throughout the aplex for example if I'm
like in a detail screen you know three
levels deep somewhere you know what if I
want to expose global navigation let the
user do a full kind of context switch
and sometimes folks use jars for that
and I don't think of that really fits in
with how they're does have they're meant
to be used on Android but certainly it's
something that's become popularized so
the current guidelines don't really you
know I don't really call for exposing
drawers in deeper levels but as Duffy
something that we can explore if you
guys have I guess feedback or or um you
know I guess arguments either way in
this direction feel free to speak up I
miss you guys it's kind of dictated by
the contents of what if you have a
strong hierarchy to your content then I
feel like you know the up button should
always take you up through that the
hierarchy of content and it shouldn't be
like but expects in the drawer yeah it's
fair um anybody else any other thoughts
on actually this is one thing that say
is is pretty common right i mean is is
using the drawer for global access like
using the inside of the up icon and or
the up carrot in the app icon using kind
of the three horizontal lines and um and
you guys can't really see who's talking
cuz i'm sharing the Hangout screen but
um you know something something like
that is is a little more comment on
other platforms and so you know it's
definitely something that I think that
we should try to standardize on at some
point in the future I'm actually a
little point about the the three
be horizontal lines is um somebody
called out the hamburger icon because
it's basically you know two slices of
two buns or whatever and then a piece
like you know a patty and meat patty in
between but yeah it's nothing like
something that's that's been used
throughout and I think that users
understand what it is the the three
horizontal lines but really kind of the
the current guidelines are for the app
icon and the up carrot well let me let
me just jump into some of the unofficial
stuff before I take the screen off so
you can see our faces again so like like
the current guidelines say you know only
at the top level the up up icon or up
karen app icon it should also not slide
the action bar so this is a point of
contention this is definitely something
that is a little inconsistent right now
across Google Apps so the Google+ app
for example does slide the action bar
out of the way to make room for the jar
the YouTube app does not we definitely
recommend not sliding the action bar out
of the way and there's I think there's
really two reasons for that the first is
that from a framework standpoint from a
development standpoint it's actually
kind of difficult to do that um and it
kind of imposes extra you know effort
and extra work to get that done and some
people say you know in in that case
let's just recreate the action bar let's
just re implement the action bar so that
we can start it out of the way and
that's not really something that you
should be doing because there's a lot of
kind of nuances with how the action bar
is implemented so you should try to
avoid implementing the action bar and
you're on your own on the other point is
that you know the action bar is really
kind of a core navigational anchor it's
really really the number one structural
component of an app I'd say and so
moving that out of the way kind of
slowly deteriorates deteriorates this
kind of relationship the user has with
that action bar you know making it
making sure that it's stable is very
very important and if you start moving
it out of the way and sliding it away
and so on um they could potentially
deteriorate the experience so those are
the two points that I'd say about
sliding the action bar um and then again
edge swipe or full swipe and then the
other thing that that folks sometimes
put into the
into the navigation drawer it's things
like settings and help and we really
don't recommend putting things like
settings and help there because that's
where those are really meant to be in
the action overflow the action overflow
is kind of those three vertical dots in
the action bar that you know that when
you press them used to kind of
additional actions that you can take and
so settings help about feedback terms of
service privacy policy things like that
those are really kind of overflow items
and so we feel that those should belong
in an action overflow and not in the
navigation drawer so these are kind of
be the kind of unofficial other items
I'd add to our official guidelines but
certainly in terms of just turn off the
screen share there in terms of you know
where we're going with the guidelines i
think that there's definitely a lot that
we can add to the current set of
guidelines and that's something that
will be will be doing in the future it's
just a question of time and resources so
hopefully at some point will be anybody
have any other thoughts navigation
drawer i just kind of did a big spiel
and took a lot of time to talk about it
but if you have any thoughts it's a
pretty big guy what one quick thing i
want to mention is um how you said don't
move the action bar out of the way other
kind of works in with how you you also
mentioned that settings about help
should be in the overflow I see a lot of
people put those things in the in their
drawer because they've slid across the
action bar and they'll the overflows
that will no longer accessible so it's
another good reason to keep the action
by in place that you can keep that
overflow still accessible mm-hmm no it's
good sorry did it keep it to navigation
option as well I think because you have
this extra real estate people get
tempted to dump all sorts of extra
information in there and I think that
really waters down this power is a
navigational tool I tend to include is
very similar to the spin and navigation
like you might see in google maps for
example it's a similar thing but you
know if you have a larger list of items
you can become unwieldy in that spinner
and harder to do so i think the drawer
can be a good alternative there and as
well as not sacrificing some real estate
so don't be tempted to just Chuck
any other thing in there because you had
some more space and you know another
vertically scrolling container mm-hmm so
I just water if you guys have had any
chance to do any usability testing a
kind of have how users see the the site
navigation which column decks off of
back button as I know you guys tried the
verge application I don't know if they
fixed it but when it first launched the
site navigation actually was very
difficult to use because it didn't make
sense when you when you back to you
actually anything with skipper squeeze I
think your google application is quite
quite good but I don't know if I'm just
a special user or how uses in general
feel where the back should take you
after you navigate it from the side mini
I don't know too much about the research
we've done specifically around
navigation drawers I'm sure that we've
done some amount of research but I
really know the details we definitely
did research on I know we did a whole
bunch of research on the action bar and
up icon and that was kind of that was a
few years ago maybe two years ago we did
a big study on that but um I think that
a lot of our guidance is it as a result
of direct user testing with that but the
navigation drawer I'm not really sure
you know what kind of formal testing
we've done on it so I definitely know
how to answer that question I think a
lot of the witness wear them back
navigation falls out from whether or not
you make it globally accessible as well
because if you have applications such as
safe spotify also know that which lets
you get to the side roll from anywhere
then you can build up these incredibly
long back stack which gets quite
complicated whereas if you do stick to
thee and the guidelines the Romans and
official guidelines I've only making it
available from top level and navigation
and screens then you don't get these
very very complex and navigation stacks
and I think the back button becomes a
lot clearer it's fair point you guys
have any thoughts I mean this isn't
again this is since this is a conic of
discussion in QA I don't want to just be
you know spewing out recommendations
from from our team I'd love to hear you
guys as thoughts on what's the right way
to do it or even like you know if you
don't like the up icon and this is
definitely something that's been brought
up before if you don't like you know
using the up icon or the up care
for this purpose you know what are the
things if you thought about and things
like that so this is not just for like
official guidance you guys have thoughts
and please do share yeah edly in the
comments check chimes in that the burger
menu is getting quite common in chrome
uses the icon for the one I think chrome
uses that icon in yes okay yum burger
icon yeah they use that on on the
desktop right for the whiskey for the
overflow I'd say it's a little different
you know you can't really compare two
very distinct platforms like I mean um
if you look at the desktop platform
versus you know Android they're
definitely different you know norms on
each so you know even iconography you
know even the direction of like you know
if there's a search icon where the
handle is is it to the left or to the
right even little things like that I
mean they can differ across platforms so
I'd say that you know it's more
important than to be consistent within
Android rather than consistent across
you know different platforms so yeah
it's not increasing its on google com
it's google to come on mobile you get to
the meeting it's fair that's right
mostly if I see swiping navigations I'm
cleaning the concept uh people sending
me concept and want a feedback from me
and um I say mostly it's messy to put
all the functionality in this menu and
everything is fine and if you have
something like a shopping application
they do the whole functionality for a
shopping basket and all this stuff in
slight menu and then they want a
secondary action bar to handle the
functionalities for the shopping basket
and all these stuff and mostly if you're
cleaning up the navigation the secondary
action bar is gone that's what I learned
in the past yeah I mean you some e
jar as the main navigation its I use it
as a last resource I mean if you don't
have any other way to show visually on
the app d sections oh there but I think
it's very very easy to just throw
everything in there and forget about it
and yeah it I mean it commented right
it's not right because the users are not
seen and if the users have not seen they
probably not going to remember that they
have that it's there so I think it's a
trend it's obviously a trend a lot of
people are using it better I don't think
I think it's like um okay we don't know
how we build Creole mobile use cases and
then we put on the menu and we have the
whole system on Android but it is a
trend right it's definitely it's
definitely a trend that you know that
folks are doing and I think that it like
aj says it's kind of you know it's
becoming more and more like a default
and what it should be is really a last
resort and i think that they're two
points want to make their you know the
first is that you know sometimes there
are jars that are that have three items
in the left right in the in the left
pane you swipe it open and there's three
items there um drawers are really just
replacements for tabs in that case so
it's really just an alternative
presentation of horizontal tabs at the
top of the screen and so you know that
point why don't you just you know simply
use tabs or use a spinner something
that's it's less heavy weight and and
more immediate more immediately visible
and the other point I wanted to make is
that you know this is actually this
reminds me of one of the problems that
we saw with the menu button the original
menu button on older devices one of the
problems was that people were putting
core functionality into something that
wasn't immediately visible and something
that wasn't immediately kind of it
wasn't immediately clear what
functionality was available and so you
know you would press the menu button and
hope that there's interesting stuff in
there hope that the thing that you're
trying to do is in there it wasn't
immediately on screen one of the reasons
we actually came up with the action bar
pattern with
to put more fundamental actions in
navigation on screen and I think that
would the jar we're seeing kind of the
reverse of that we're putting less and
less stuff on screen for the purposes of
you know making or optimizing you know
the real estate for content I think that
there's probably a better balance to be
struck in a lot of cases between content
and chrome you still want to show you
know the key you know most important
navigation in some way as well as you
know your content but I'm I'd say that
you know what AJ says is right i mean it
shouldn't be a default it should really
be kind of a last resort if there's no
other pattern that works really well in
the dramatics um cause the product
managers say we want catalog in our app
chopping application we want a category
view we want all these stuff we want in
this little small application and then
you have too much they can't develop a
mobile application with maybe three
useful functionalities that's the mobile
case that's the reason why we have
mobile I'm maybe enough store and I will
order the shoes at home delivery service
so one case just ordering and I think
messy point or the too much
functionalities it's a little bit I
Windows Explorer I think it's really up
to up to us as you know the designers to
to talk to folks like that and say you
know you really need to optimize around
the core competencies in core know best
use cases of your app like make sure
that the two or three things that users
are expecting to do with your app we're
really easy and straightforward and you
know if folks that they're asking for
these apps to be built site you know but
we need like 78 you know nine different
functions and you know I guess it's the
job of the designers to say given those
nine functions how do we best present
these not as functions but as as flows
and as kind of benefits to the user so
I'd say you know maybe it's our job to
pair things down to the to the most
important and then you know put other
things in you know put other items like
you know secondary functions into
the overflow into other navigational
comments I agree I quite like it when an
app has the tight focus and doesn't try
to do everything like why not launch a
second app perhaps the different thing
yeah I'm sorry you'd help the tablet
case more on application and more
functionalities on tablet it's very nice
to Russia you've mentioned tablets but
also it makes it easy to do a
master-detail flow on tablets because
you can show that sort of draw by
default on a tablet and you have that
same UI so you can reuse over things
which makes it easier he again YouTube
does that really nicely as well so it
uses this kind of like responsive design
so when you have a certain amount of
them horizontal real estate the drawer
is open by default there are positives
do it what I what I see in the past is
okay other systems like is working
really straight they are working like
that deeper deeper deeper deeper in the
application and Android works a little
bit more kotick but every time step
click very close to the user ah Oh
marine still there think Marie may have
frozen chicken coop uh okay well when
she gets back we'll let her finish that
thought um but uh before we move on we
have five minutes left does anybody else
have been no you know motivated
questions oh yeah yeah we should
probably jump into the moderate we're
Marina returned she can finish your
thought before I jump into the monitors
anybody else have any anything they'd
like to bring up okay talk about the a
quick return bar there's are ya own that
you presented in their code and I shared
one that does an implementation like in
Google+ rich on the bottom hello days
right Los it sorry I understand
yeah it last folks okay to the heat
Roman what's his name Laura's Vogel
Batman a large Berkman okay yeah
that's my love you so Dioner given you
did you want to like a make a point
about its usefulness or do you have any
questions about it yeah I'm just curious
like so there's a little bit of
weirdness about scrolling up bring
something from the bottom that the
advantage of person said it's on the
bottom so it's lot it's a lot closer to
your your finger maybe if you're
scrolling up you just draw up a
loneliness right there if you're like
strictly on like a tablet or something
or if you scroll up and the things at
the top then it's really far away so
here's like there what's the ideas about
like should it be on the top or bottom
or they were just a weird pattern and
olive oil I think um I think that the
the placement is generally probably
better to put at the top it's a little
more natural I'd say that the Google+
app in general you know when talking
about things that Google Plus that does
it's a little more experimental on the
UI side there they're definitely drawing
lots and lots of things and you know
some of them work really well some of
them are really just you know
experiments that they'll pull out so I
wouldn't say that you know follow the
Google+ app you know why you know to the
T as to what it does um but specifically
in this case I think one of the reasons
that they moved it down is that it
wasn't like the iconography that they
were using wasn't as clear as it could
be and then they wanted to show text as
well and then at that point you know the
the bar itself became quite large so it
became just kind of a little a little
bit of a burden at the very top of the
screen so they moved it to the bottom
but I don't think that's really
finalized I don't really know if it's
finalized but certainly it's stuff that
we're still exploring but I'd say that
by default you should probably use you
know sticky bars at the top unless it's
really kind of following you're spilling
gesture so if you're scrolling down and
you want to show something at the very
bottom like for example you know jump to
the bottom I don't know if this is very
common but you know your jump to the top
or jump to the bottom if it's if it's
showing up in the direction you're
scrolling the probably makes sense so if
you're scrolling up probably showing
something at the top is
better one decisions that I quite like
is the end the foursquare app just ain't
quite nice way and as you scrolling down
your feet if you go back to the top it
actually pops up some kind of like two
filters at the bottom which is actually
quite nice way of doing it so it doesn't
do it just with the general scrolling up
but just when you reach the very top it
pops in which are quite like spear um
Marie did you want to finish your
thought real quick it's not really
stable today that's right well we'll
follow up over a google plus no problem
I city can handle the topic very careful
um so um let's see Andy Andrews you have
any other questions on the quicker it
sternum yeah it's it's not really a
formalized pattern the quick return and
actually that that name is just
something that me and Nick came up with
it's not really a formal thing but
certainly there's I think in general
when when there's something that's not
documented in our official guidelines we
have a bug filed and eternally to make
sure that it gets documented it's just a
question of time and resources so at
some point we'll have probably some more
guidance on quick return hmm I have a
question about resources yeah sure um so
mostly i'm i'm working for in the past
now i'm employed by the voter but in the
past i'm working for a lot of agencies
creative agencies they doing something
like catalogue or shopping or tools or
gadgets or automotive if for sports
brands all this stuff and I I try to
show them how Android works and big
thanks to my friend Martin tilaka who is
who um take maybe 30 screenshots from
ice cream sandwich and i have now 30
screenshots with his private mail
account on all the private stuff but i
use this stuff to show the yeah
the designers to look how Android is
today and what I really need is maybe
just just screenshots from a actual
system and Nexus 4 I I haven't the nexus
4 i have just just older phones i prefer
the older phones actuate not just
because they are they have keyboards a
big aj is signing in an agreement right
yeah i mean right now it's really really
hard to find screenshots up meet the
nexus 10 resolution it's you can't find
I can I can't there are no it's just
just her just how I system application
go out when double X HD PA counting you
better guys have a couple of screenshots
for you I will say this if you guys are
so if there are specific screenshots
that you guys need like I mean it's you
know it's obvious that we can't all by
every device if you guys need certain
screenshots at any point you know just
let us know publicly um we'll we'll
share publicly me we're more than happy
to do that we have a bunch of test
account so I know this isn't like like
an official resource but is nothing
something that we can help with you know
one-off cases but certainly you know we
do plan on updating the design site with
this kind of stuff so it well I don't
know if it will be full resolution but
certainly like we want to make sure that
the Zion site is up to date so that you
can share at least those screenshots
those kind of frame screen travel with
uh with your product managers and
clients and such yeah I always say like
whenever I start working with designer
who's not work with Android before I
always encourage them if they can get
all of a device and just get get used to
the patterns and so on I might know that
might not be possible depending on your
clients or whatever it is but like
that's going to be the first bad
situation if not there's always the
emulator ever I can tell you from time
to time I never get my device back um I
think we're I think we're losing our
room and I think we're a little over
time so let's stop there
and continue you know sometime the next
few weeks I think we should do more of
these and probably unlike deeper dives
into specific subjects but thanks
everybody for joining and I'm you know
definitely we have food for thought and
more folks to file in terms of you know
more design resources to come out with
um so again thanks for joining and i
will see you hopefully next week can I
go yeah yeah I fine